hey do you want to get dinner tomorrow
night laid you were gonna say late well
it's always help you it is isn't it I
love dinner with you though should we
yeah can you get me late
now let's see wait
105. yeah in your bra you're honor item
check you would overactor
[Applause]
Jesus
let's take a walk
crap
he took off on us
what
one more one you'll be a light bulb
what
that's called
it's called misdirection
so don't stare at him whatever you do
some martyr martyr
s
I'm not being a martyr I'm who the hell
am I
oh yeah [ __ ] okay martyr I'm not being a
martyr I'm the victim here
don't you smile don't you smile right
now I swear remember Good Fellows
Martin Scorsese uses super slow motion
to enhance his chilling tale of four
okay what am I saying remember
Goodfellas Martin Scorsese is a super
slow motion photography to enhance his
chilling tale of five Men and a Baby
[Laughter]
oh
okay that's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
if I was a boxer I would
bounce those things like Sugar Ray
Leonard I'm sure
[Music]
I'm a very weird blood type I'm a B
positive hmm
sounds delicious
Mrs Cole
[Music]
a goose
[Applause]
I'm Bruce Nolan
and that's the way the cookie crumbles
foreign
[Laughter]
positive I'd be positive okay sorry I
have a very
[Laughter]
rare blood type I'm AB negative I'm I be
positive am I a b negative I don't know
what you are anymore including
prenuptial agreements
[Music]
oh God
see he's nuts
[Laughter]
see I'm
kind of busy
rain check
I'll hold you to it
oh okay
can you get crabs have you ever had what
thank you have you ever had crabs
not this big
[Laughter]
God
[Laughter]
it was a long way getting there
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Mommy
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah well uh they're you know their
store houses all over the world you know
all over the year with tons of stuff on
ice and it's sorry
[Laughter]
projector yeah yeah yeah
oh wow okay let me just laugh some more
no because I can't remember
foreign
[Music]
it's the Creator screwed up
no laughing oh what a tangled web wee
wee when first we practice
I'm gonna say it right
[Music]
now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
who can take a rainbow wrap it in a sign
so get in the Sun and make a grillby
lemon pie
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Laughter]
let's go Grace
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
when dinosaurs ruled the Earth
[Music]